this is Lizzy James speaking on behalf
of Alessandra Barbosa the latest Call of
Duty from Infinity Ward shipped without
an answer - black ops force blackout but
it has since been supplemented by
warzone a completely standalone battle
royale built off of the backbone of
modern warfare not only is it a smarter
way to ensure it's not tied to each
annual release in the series but warzone
gives the series its own identity within
the competitive genre
[Music]
it might not be apparent at first though
especially when you take into
consideration how much warzone borrows
from other popular battle royale games
it incorporates a ping system similar to
the one in apex legends albeit map to a
button that's harder to reach quickly
mitigating some of its convenience it
plays out on a massive map akin to
player unknowns battlegrounds where
large swaths of open land are right for
snipers while dense suburbs make for
exhilarating skirmishes unlike the ones
in fortnight color-coded chests
overflowing with loot are easy to hunt
down when you are within earshot of
their signature emanating jingle none of
these competitors are defined solely by
the elements warzone borrows from them
and war zone isn't defined by the sum of
their parts instead warzone uses them to
establish a solid foundation for its own
distinct elements it starts with a
larger play account than the
aforementioned battle royale games with
warzone currently supporting up to 150
players per match with modes for
three-person squads or solo play having
so many players active at once keeps you
constantly on alert but also increases
the odds that you'll at least have some
action and likely a handful of kills
each match this makes even some of the
least successful drops feel worthwhile
you're likely to feel right at home with
many areas of war zones map to if you've
already been playing Modern Warfare many
of its named areas use identical layouts
as those in modern warfare proper as
well as previous installments so you can
navigate them using muscle memory and
their intuitive enough to learn from
scratch - it's easy to lose pursuers in
the twisting streets of downtown or hide
in the large industrial factories of the
lumberyard the variety in verticality
forces you to think about what
advantages you might reap with the extra
elevation against the disadvantages of
trapping yourself in a narrow hallway to
get there first war zone minimizes
downtime encouraging you to get into a
fight with an aggressively fast closing
circle and streamlined mechanics
governing your loot unlike most other
games in the genre war zone doesn't task
you with micromanaging items in a
limited space backpack instead you have
predefined slots of ammunition types
armor plating and cash the rest of your
loadout works identically to a standard
modern warfare multiplayer match you
have two weapon slots one lethal grenade
and one utility grenade slot each and
one slot for field equipment perks like
FMJ ammunition recon drones and more
weapons dropped with attachments already
equipped based on their overall rarity
and there's no option to customize them
outside of what they already feature
this makes early looting extremely quick
it's easy to find two suitable primary
weapons and stockpile some ammunition
early on which lets you focus more on
hunting other players than staying out
of sight in pursuit of attachments to
your gear it also feeds into war zones
changes to both an in-game economy and
its principles around respawning both of
which benefit from allowing you to go
from your starting pistol to battle
ready in a few minutes flat cash is
central to warzone spin on the genre you
earn cash by looting it killing other
players or completing small optional
objectives by stations are littered
around the map and if you have the cash
you can spend it not only on kill
streaks but also useful gear like
additional armor plating and self revive
kits the most expensive purchase is a
full loadout drop letting you airdrop in
a crate and equip your squad with their
own handcrafted load outs and perks from
their own inventories this is the
largest twist in warzone in terms of its
effect on the overall focus of the
are the battle Royales force you to make
do with what you can scavenge but war
zone shifts up focus on collecting as
much cash as you can and getting the
load out of your choice despite being
the most expensive purchase right now
it's incredibly easy to secure enough
money within the opening moments of a
match
to purchase a drop for your pre-made
loadouts the inclusion of a loadout drop
dilutes the dynamism of matches by
making loot count for a lot less it's no
longer a scrappy Russia to try and equip
yourself with what you can find but a
brief interlude before hunting other
players with weapons you've specifically
chosen for warzone and its structure I
found more fun in matches where I was
playing on the edge forced to make do
with average rated weapons with poor
scopes that forced me to put my battles
wisely there's opportunity for this not
only at the start of a warzone match but
throughout one - thanks to a liberal
respawn system that frequently feeds you
back into the game when you're killed
for the first time you're transported to
the gulag and forced to face off against
one other player to secure your freedom
and respawn into the match these bouts
are quick and messy rewarding fast
reflexes and pinpoint aim it feels great
to earn your place back in a match after
disappointing death but it also places
you immediately on the backfoot
as your spawned back in without any of
your loot if you fail in the gulag or
subsequently died after having respawned
you can still be revived indefinitely by
teammates at by stations if you're
playing with a squad of course as a
hefty fee attributed to each respawn but
it slow enough to encourage your squad
to seek out your revival without giving
up on it entirely once you've gone down
it also redefines what a death means in
battle royale warzone doesn't let you
linger after successful skirmish forcing
you to hurry through your opponent's
drop loot and prepare for the
possibility of retaliation it keeps you
looking over your shoulder at all times
scanning the horizon for a vengeful
scope taking aim at your head it's
equally exhilarating to lose to a squad
and deliver retribution
after a quick visit to the Gulag
fighting back from nothing to overcome
your rivals is incredibly rewarding
whether you're playing with the team or
solo though in squads you have more
opportunities to do so in addition to
warzone standard battle royale mode is
plunder which is far less noteworthy
than the main attraction despite being
in new game mode entirely set on the
same map and with the same 150 players
split into teams of three
plunder shifts the objective from
survival to looting the overall goal is
to hoard as much cash as
can depositing your personal stashes at
helicopter drop points squads currently
leading the standings are marked on the
map giving you a clear view of your
competitors and attracting players to
common areas for largely chaotic fights
respawns are unlimited in plundered to
dying only penalizes you by resetting
your carried cash and forcing you to sit
through a lengthy respawn timer plunder
is sound mechanically but it's simply
unacceptable banked 1 million dollars
for the most part the majority of
players are centralized on one part of
the map all fighting over the same pool
of money in firefights where bullets are
coming from every direction even though
Battle Royale lacks a strict structure
it's closing circle does move players in
a common direction which forces dynamic
skirmishes that can lead to exciting and
unexpected gameplay stories plunders
static nature lacks the same excitement
war zone is a great sophomore attempt at
a battle royale from Call of Duty which
finally manages to carve out its own
identity with interesting spins on the
existing formula its subversion of death
and the nail-biting gulag joules give
you more ways to stay in a match while
also forcing you to be aware of your
surroundings even after wiping a rifle
squad
it's looting as streamlined enough to
make early moments feel fast but warzone
also loses some of the messy magic from
hobbled together loadouts by letting you
drop in pre-built ones far too easily
and frequently still if you're
comfortable with Call of Duty's latest
iteration of multiplayer antics and
thrive in the stressful setting of
battle Royales warzone is a strong
contender for your attention
[Music]